good morning everyone
my friend
joginder singh
is in ninja
no he doesn't specialize in covert
warfare like these guys do
but he is fighting a war
he's fighting a war against banks and
traditional financial institutions
who don't find him loanworthy
they call him a ninja
because according to them
he has no income
no job and no assets
i repeat
joginder cannot provide the paperwork to
banks that they require
so they call him a ninja with no income
no job and no assets
but joginder does have a job and he does
have assets he just doesn't have
paperwork to prove for it
he's a farmer in northwestern india in
punjab
in fact he provides jobs for 15
labourers on his farm every year
now joginder is a progressive farmer
he wants to get a loan for his first
tractor to increase the yield to
increase the output of his farm
but banks won't fund him
so at this point i want to ask the
audience show of hands
how many of you have heard of micro
finance
this is stanford so this i'd say that's
about 100 of you nearly
great well it turns out joginder has
approached microfinance companies as
well
and
they don't really meet his need
unfortunately because a tractor costs
nearly ten thousand dollars in india
and uh microfinance companies typically
don't go beyond five six thousand
dollars in funding
so he's stuck
well joginder's example was a very
extreme case of a small business that
was underfunded
i want to show you um you know a very
simple image of
stacking up the number of corporations
in a developing country and if you do
that the bottom 70
of corporations are micro enterprises
having less than 10 employees and less
than a hundred thousand dollars us
dollars in annual revenue
that's really the focus of microfinance
companies
the top one percent represent the
multinationals and the large enterprises
and uh those are uh you know looked
after by banks
so really you have a you know large
sizable chunk of um percent of the
enterprises in a developing country such
as india which are underfunded
now jorgender's again was an extreme
example given
but i want to kind of talk to you about
what impact these small businesses have
um
not only on an economy such as india but
uh in the world at large
in india small businesses contribute
more than half of the manufacturing
output and half of the exports
coming out of the country that's nearly
20 the gdp of india and yet more than 90
percent of them are self-funded they
lack access to credit
abstracting to the world at large
one-third of the globe's population is
employed by small businesses and they
are underfunded
sitting here in the us you know we think
we're fairly insulated from such
phenomenon
turns out surprisingly that nearly 30
percent of the u.s population has no
savings account
in fact according to forbes
the second biggest concern
on the mind of a small business owner is
access to credit
so i want to do two things in my talk
today
one
i want to share with you my vision for
how financial inclusion can have an
impact on these small businesses
and two
i would ask for your help in helping me
reach out to the lenders of the world
so financial inclusion what about it
wikipedia describes financial inclusion
to be the cost-effective delivery
of financial of affordable financial
services to the poor of the world
i want to give you the example of one
organization
attempting to do this this is my family
business back home in india
magma fincorp
uh we give loans to the underbanked and
the unbanked population in the country
and uh we've been doing this for uh you
know quite long and i think we've
started to get good at it out of every
1000 loans that we give only two loans
go go bad
that's a 0.2 default rate
giving loans to traditionally riskier
customers
having a default rate that's 17 times
better than the public bank in india
this is not by fluke we're actually been
doing this for quite some time and
managing three and a half us billion in
assets
we give large loans
the average ticket size would be close
to around fourteen thousand dollars
these are large loans this allows us to
actually invest the time and effort
required to collect the data because in
india you know you don't have data such
available so readily
and do a lot of capital one style
analytics on this data
and because we're reasonably sure that
our customers will be able to pay us
back we can provide low interest rates
how do we do it
one we get to know our partner really
really well
banks also require paperwork you know
but they're very rigid we actually
provide a choice of 65 different
documents from which the partner can you
know kind of tell us who they are we get
to know how stable they are in that are
they moving their home a lot are they
moving their job a lot we even get to
know their neighborhood and their social
circles that gives us an idea of the
social equity of the person which has an
impact on their repayment rates
second and this is key
is we
evaluate their income in non-traditional
ways so for example for joginder we not
only look at his the size of his farm we
look at how many times he rotates his
crops that gives us an idea of the
output he has from the same amount of
land
we look at um we look at his home uh
joginder has a mud home but he has one
wall in his home that's a brick wall
that tells us something about the person
about the disposable income he had in
the recent past and about his ambitions
in life
next and this is also very key we give
loans for very specific purposes
in fact the loan amount goes directly to
the dealership
the tractor dealership that is providing
the asset hence we are reasonably sure
that the
money is being put to good use
uh one thing that's really critical to
our growth and our success is
innovations on the loan products
uh we try to come up with innovative
products that would meet the needs of
the entrepreneurs in our country
we've come up with a product where even
if the small business cannot provide us
their income statements
we actually provide them 65 percent of
the value of the asset that they're
purchasing for their business based on
just knowing who they are
and ensuring that they're a stable
entrepreneur
we've come up with a new product just
recently where we give a loan against
jewelry in 15 minutes now this is
actually a key uh requirement in the
indian
subcontinent you know you have a lot of
entrepreneurs who you know have a very
urgent need for cash for a recent order
that came in uh you know or they have an
emergency and and this is where this
comes in really handy and we try to keep
innovating on this
great so i've given you a very brief
sneak preview on uh you know how we do
this
and coming to the second part of my talk
i want to ask for your
help i i have a dream i believe that no
dreams should go unfulfilled
because of the lack of funds
and in order to do that in order to
reach out to the vast number of ninjas
in the world and in my country we need
to constantly keep innovating on our
credit algorithms
recently at stanford i got to know for
startup that is um looking at the social
media equity of uh of its uh you know of
customers and they create a credit score
supplement based on just that data
i got to know about a lady you know who
set up a startup which is partnering
with farmers to track their daily income
and their daily expenses
creating a credit score and then putting
them under the formal financial system
so we need to constantly keep innovating
on these algorithms and if you are
passionate about this space if you want
to know more about this space if you
just feel that it'd be nice to do some
research or 390 on this course please
come talk to
me ifc washington uh invests which is a
world bank subsidiary invest in emerging
economies uh invested in us and they
want to take us to countries um
which are behind india in the financial
inclusions you know sector
if you know of specific areas specific
uh
connections would be useful who would
benefit from a business such as this
please come talk to me
and finally branding
you know this space has been plagued
by
terrible stories of 90 interest rates uh
our first case study in ethics actually
talked about that uh you know it's been
plagued by repo men and by predatory
lending so it's not really the
greatest place to be in uh honestly if
you have ideas of how we can call
attention to the positive aspects of
this space and the people are doing good
in this space please come talk to me
finally i want to
bring back jorgender
jorgender has moved from being a ninja
to a superhero
in his community he now owns multiple
tractors a car and even his first brick
home
all you know through loans from from us
how many ninjas will you convert to
superheroes
thank you